nein ist es antworten gab was hast du
dir einfach geht das stimmt max und ich
haben uns quasi zeitgleich unabhängig
voneinander einen amazon
überraschungspaket wir stellt der
unterschied war allerdings das macht
sein paket zeiten angekommen ist und
mainz wurde irgendwie versehentlich nach
wolfsburg das ist auf jeden fall ein
paket in diesem paket sind 30 oder 20
punkte drin ich weiß nicht welche größen
sich genommen habe und man hat keine
ahnung was drin ist also wirklich ein
überraschungspaket wir haben noch nicht
angeguckt werden ist bisher nur den
titel abgemacht diesen dhl poststempel
und so und ich würde sagen wie man jetzt
einfach das paket auf und greifen
abwechselnd rhein mit zwei augen und
schauen dass wir daraus ziehen werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gut machst wird max greift jetzt zum
ersten mal rein
jetzt ein paket raus und es ist
verpackungspapier verpackungspapier
freunde das lohnt sich definitiv
immer das hier und ich habe einen
dalmatiner warte mal ist das ein stift
der stift schreibt das nächste produkt
hier wird von max gezogen und er greift
das paket rein und es ist ja das ist
richtig geil global richtig geil 30 x 30
cm unter warmes wasser halten
unter warmes wasser halten und zu sehen
wie es wächst also das glück 30 mal 30
zentimeter groß wenn man einfach nur gut
wir machen jetzt erst mal dass dabei
erst mit dem sich fast schon mal
hoffentlich steht ja auch noch was drauf
dass sie ist das handtuch
2000 jahre später
[Musik]
der junge piquet ist man daran so ein
handtuch hat man aber sind wir schon
cool oder würdest du sagen bisher hat
sich schon gelohnt was zu investieren
der hang zu und rein zum 30
du hast da kannst du eine weinflasche
reinstellt okay leute das ist irgendwie
so ein nikolaus die sein mäßiges abends
tat haben da kann man das doch nur
einstellen wenn der platz steht noch ein
hütchen auf setzen also hey das ist das
ja ein micro mann ich weiß nicht was er
kann
ja das ist gestand in metalle und man
kann sich daraus einen typen zusammen
bauen der auf dem schreibtischstuhl
sitzt einfach den typen ausdrücken und
dann fort bereichen sodass man einen
typen der anderen schreibtisch sitzt
gerade jetzt endlich rein man mein gott
das ist magnetisch wir testen ob das
ganze magnetisches freunde meine wand
hin dass auch magnetisch ist einfach so
ein richtig geiler cupcake aber der hat
einfach absolut gar keine funktion also
es klebt nicht es ist nicht magnetisch
etwas auf dem tisch lägen
oh mein gott möchte weihnacht wo weiter
trainieren weil man dort vielleicht
lassen wir weihnachten fast niemand das
296 tag nicht gerade freunde prowein
acht lassen darin die weihnachten also
das war wahrscheinlich auch wieder um
eine flasche oder so all das kann es ja
auch um seine bizeps machen alt trägt
man auf der street sowie das ist echt
eine weihnachts andré das heißt dass
gemessen an der straßenbahn du kannst
dann zeigen hey und die seen pro
weihnachten ein paar
was ist das für eine scheiße geld weiter
so sieht das ganze aus ein stinknormales
populären wir können's aufklappen und
wir sehen schon oh mein gott oh mein
gott los zieht daraus wenn du dich
traust oder machst auch einmal fast
immer in solchen wer mal oh mein gott
das ist nahezu jeder kennt der taschen
wärmer das hat noch so eine süße sockel
dazu dass auf jeden fall oh mein gott
ich sag jetzt freuen ich habe der neue
sockel die ja das trägt man so sagen du
bist im falschen opfer alles klar auf
jeden fall könnt ihr das hier so knicken
kannst du klicken und dann wenn man es
geknickt hat entwickelt sich heute und
ich fange jetzt auch so das ist ein seit
sind verstreut glaube ich bin sowieso
kein extremist hast du geht einmal gott
oh mein gott auf jeden fall ist das so
eine halskette schreibt man auf einer
skala von eins bis o mein gott wie gut
die ist voll geht werfen
ich habe geschaut ich greife rein in die
box meine damen und herren meine freunde
und freundinnen und habe eine hülle für
also ok freunde das hier ist die größe
von meinem handy und das ist die größe
von der höhle altoberndorf handy drin
aber wagt das handy hier erst mal aus
ich glaube das ist das neue iphone 8
also die wollten ja von der größe
zurückgehen und auch von der grafik und
die wollten gar keine technik mehr
verbauen sondern nehmen egal ob ihre
einfach nur papier so sieht das ganze
hier aus ich kann jetzt drauf drücken
und wie sie nun ist es an was nur
mitmache auch lautsprecher auf
lautsprecher steve jobs in den himmel
wenn gott
mein leben ist ein leeres marmeladenglas
das ist übertrieben
hey guckt euch das mal an wie milchig
das ist sieht man dass was soll das der
war betäubungsmittel drin man ein
polster ist man wieder kaputt man kann
es nicht man kann das nicht mehr zu
machen leute
oh mein gott oh mein gott walther
schroth das gold 37 gold ja ich werde um
mein gott ich kriege es nicht offen und
niemand denkt zuerst es ist ein ganz
normaler stift aber nein sind dafür dass
[Musik]
das richtig in der summe so eine frisch
ausgepackten luftmatratze alter leute
aber vergesst nicht rock immer noch die
chain hier wieder etwas komisches die
verpackung sie zumindest mal nicht gott
doch beschissenes robo cup cake holte
also ich will niemand kann so was rein
packe ich würde niemals einen kaputt
machen so mini kleine dinge die aus dem
gewitter das ist ungefähr der größe der
größten herzens wie viele leute machen
sich tatsächlich selbst cupcakes
zweitens wie viele leute man sich capex
in roboter formen wir zählen ab sofort
dazu den fuß ein fußwärmer alten 5 er
mit dem fuß drin das heißt du uns voll
winter thema sex und nikolaus zeugt
zumindest mal nicht so ekelhaft ich weiß
nicht wie das ganze funktionieren soll
wir jetzt keinen drückt oder irgendwie
sowas drin es ist schon wahr
es wird schon langsam waren wenn man
sich aber darauf stand glaube ich ist
das geil in der woche das ist das ist
bisher mit das beste was da drin war
neben unserem wiki handtuch ein kleiner
schmutziger panda bear hier definitiv
schon von jemanden kennen einander
handytasche mit rückzugs funktionen ein
euro drauf das heißt rückzug funktion
ich ganz gut so du kannst dein hätten
wir haben ja jeder das neue iphone 8 und
das kann man hier reinstecken jetzt erst
mal das iphone 8 hier drehen und jetzt
kann ich nämlich theoretisch ihr
anziehen
all das passiert gar nix alter ist
dieses ding geil junge was obwohl darauf
wie man mit dem iphone ab haben sich
ebenfalls
du willst du das große haben
man legt das irgendwie auf seine schuhe
dann kann man es anmalen und dann kann
man sich so tolle bunte schuhe selbst
machen das doch mal bei babys machen
meine frohe weihnachten sind das ab dann
ist das nicht manchmal eine gängige
respektiert sagt ein gefühl von holiday
gelte die osta weiter hinten an die wand
fakten sofort als 2000 jahre später
leute und welche angeregt hat das ding
ihren platz gefunden sein traum
ich weiß nicht ob jetzt so was drin ist
aber mag einfach befreien und sie haben
bis noch papier und wir haben noch mehr
papier und wir haben das beste kommt zum
schluss ein russischer schlüsselanhänger
aus holz von der dicken frau alter und
wir haben noch einen hut
lasst doch mal leichter freunde das war
das beste überraschungspaket von
amazon.de aufgenommen wurde
das ist jetzt ihr vom video meine damen
und herren es euch gefallen hat das
gerne mal wenn wir das noch mal machen
sollen mit einem anderen
überraschungspaket weil das sind ja
immer unterschiedliche sachen drin denn
hier jetzt noch dran sein und euch das
video wirklich bis zur wende gegeben hat
dann schreibt mal amazonen in die
kommentare
und jetzt will ich sagen meine damen und
herren kommen
doch die wir alle gewartet haben max
hier auch die ganze zeit auf jeden fall
würde sagen roll die austro das was ihr
vom video das was jetzt hier vom video
hier können jetzt jemanden kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
aus checken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]